was mich am meisten aufstieg ist die
burg bewegung also die bewegung die von
sich behauptet dass sie gegen rassismus
kämpft und für soziale gerechtigkeit
wieso weiß ich in dieser bewegung eine
ideologie eingeschlichen hat die selbst
rassistisch ist zum beispiel hat die
humboldt universität in berlin eine
stellenausschreibung veröffentlicht in
der sie wirklich gefordert hat das weiße
personen sich nicht bewerben sollen ein
anderes beispiel es gibt in deutschland
anti rassismus seminare in denen man
weiße schüler dazu denkt sich für die
hautfarbe zu schämen was teilweise so
weit geht dass die schüler in tränen
ausbrechen also man sollte menschen
demütigen nur weil sie weiß sind das nur
zwei beispiele dafür wie diese wolke
vermeintlich antirassistische bewegungen
gerade unter unser bildungssystem
beeinflusst und ich finde es kann
einfach nicht sein dass wir tatenlos
zusehen und es nicht einfach mal mehr
aufregen und uns auch mal angucken was
wird eigentlich was geht eigentlich in
den ministerien ab was
welche forschung ist es überhaupt die
gerade so massiv unsere schulen unsicher
universitäten und unsere lehrer
beeinflusst und da weiß nicht also ich
finde eigentlich keine andere worte
dafür aus so zu sagen wir müssen endlich
mehr tun um diese wolken bewegungen oder
auch ihre verstrickungen in die
wissenschaft und wie gesagt in die
pädagogik etwas entgegenzusetzen
ja es läuft ja vieles verkehr das ist
stimmt schon wenn man sich die beispiel
anhört kann man nur
denkbar
gleichzeitig braucht jede bewegung und
es sind ja auch bewegungen die firma
gleichberechtigung für mehr
chancengerechtigkeit auch für die
unterschiedlichen minderheiten kämpfen
menschen dieses vorantreiben muss meine
feste überzeugung das ist nicht immer so
ja weil diese leute kämpfen nicht für
die rechte von minderheiten also dass
man da muss man wirklich unterscheiden
natürlich gibt es die kirche bewegung
gibt es antirassisten gibt es
antifaschisten den sehr gutes ziel haben
und eben überhaupt nicht ideologisch
sind sondern sich wirklich für die
schwächsten und ärmsten in der
gesellschaft einsetzen aber diese idee
von den nicht gedacht die wirklich
behaupten sie machen eine forschung die
für soziale gerechtigkeit ist die
kümmern sich nicht um die interessen der
ärmsten und schwächsten schwächsten
sondern etablieren ein neues taxi denken
sie etablieren ein neues denken sie
würden sicherlich ablehnen zu sagen dass
sie neues rasse denken etablieren sind
sagen wir kümmern uns darum dass alle
rasten gleich behandelt werden und
fördern dadurch das ansehen oder machen
dass dadurch dass wir das ansehen von
ein seemann weiter abwertet einzelnen
hervorheben und wir schließen daraus
dass sie teilweise ab denn ich habe
letztens mit zwei dunkelhäutigen
bekannten an einem tisch gesessen in
einem restaurant mit hätte die erfahrung
wie man da tatsächlich auch behandelt
wird das ist klingt ganz subjektiv und
und doof ich weiß das aber das habe ich
zum ersten mal ich habe auch so
wahrgenommen immer noch in einer
liberalen statt die berlin und also kann
es auch nicht sein und ich habe
verständnis für all diejenigen die das
nach vorne treiben wollen jede bewegung
braucht menschen die etwas radikaler
angehen auch wenn wir sagen das ist
nicht kommen sense ist und nicht politik
ein und jede bewegung braucht eine che
guevara eine kg ware oder wie man sie
nennen will auch alice schwarzer bei den
frauenrechten haben wir genau so
verteufelt vor vielen jahren und
trotzdem hat sie was bewegt ja aber die
staunt der zuwegung von alice schwarzer
kam nie auf die idee menschen aufgrund
der hautfarbe irgendetwas zu und männer
aufgrund ihres besonderen
organischen
einzelteilen diese leute diese leute
sterben aufsätze wissenschaftliche
aufsätze in denen sie sagen dass kinder
an psychischen störungen erkrankt sind
weil sie weiß sind das hat nichts mehr
zu tun das sind nicht nur spinner dies
sind jeder bewegung gibt sondern das ist
da gibt es auch schon mega viel
forschungs über eine ganz ausgeklügelte
totalitäre ideologie die versucht
menschen in kollektive stereotype und
gruppen zu lassen wie wir das schon
hatten beim installieren es muss genau
das gleiche das kommt jetzt wieder und
verkauft sich das antirassismus wir
müssen aus der das thema wichtig sind
und sich so irgendwie bin ich weiß
welche spinnen sie malen aber das sind
nicht nur irgendwelche spinner das ist
wirklich gefährlich was gerade abgeht
machen wir die gesunde etwas größer ihr
beide schauten zu wie ist eure meinung
dazu wer will starken ja also ich glaube
wenn ich mir momentan anschaue was wir
auch hier in deutschland erleben das
thema denk und sprechverbote wie gehen
wir mit benachteiligten vielleicht mit
rassen et cetera um
muss ich ganz klar sagen mir wäre es
viel wichtiger dass wir auch so handeln
und dass wir nicht nur alles auch über
die sprache definieren also mir kommt
dann bei diesem ganzen thema folk
bewegung auch diese themen auf den tisch
wie was dürfen wir noch sagen was dürfen
wir nicht mehr sagen indiana
zigeunerschnitzel das moore im café uns
wird er mittlerweile
wenn wir nicht uns an diesen diese
bewegung anschließend nicht zu sprechen
und denken dass wir gleich schon ein
schlechter mensch sind und uns schlecht
fühlen und das macht mir auch ein ganz
mulmiges gefühl verhandeln wir schauen
wo kommen diese bewegungen her die sind
ja meistens haben ihren anspruch
ursprung ja auch im linken milieu und
von daher machen wir solche themen auch
teilweise angst wenn wir wirklich in die
richtung gehen was darf man noch was
darf man nicht mehr und es wird immer
massiver zurzeit
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass
ich da nicht allzu viel über diese
bewegung weiß und dementsprechend würde
ich mich an dieser diskussion nicht zu
sehr beteiligen wollen weil ich eine
ähnliche meinung wie bella vertrete wo
ich sage okay
minderheiten und
bewegungen die die minderheiten schützen
sollen brauchen irgendwo auch
experimentierraum um was auszuprobieren
wenn es aber so ist wie du es gerade
darstellt das andere rechte beschnitten
werden finde ich das nicht in ordnung
aber ich kann das nicht beurteilen ich
bin da nicht allzu tief drinnen als ich
das dazu sagen kann immer was sich in
den letzten monaten vielleicht sogar
jahren durch einen monat nicht schon
gewandelt hat in bezug auf die enter das
war vor sechs monaten noch so ein
schenkelklopfer dann konnte man sich in
der talkshow selbst hofft diese ganze
gender kram ist oder das allerletzte
natürlich hat die community geschrien
aber 70 prozent der tochter war echt
schön hast du ja
ja ja ich mache mal innen und roten oder
so aber ich finde warum soll man immer
pilot sagen es sind pilotinnen und so
war es und natürlich ist das eine
verkürzung der
berufswahl und wird auch der der der
kompetenz wenn nicht nur die männliche
form nehme ich habe am anfang auch
gedacht ich bin da wirklich dahin geht
also will ich sagen habe dazu gesagt ich
finde es normal
das generische maß bedienung by the way
ist nicht nur die männliche form also
dass genetische marge bedienung ist ein
generikum und kein sex source also pilot
ist mann und frau wenn sie sagen die
piloten fliegen gerade über stuttgart
wieder jedes gern wieso ist das auch die
frau bei der die mannschaften konnte
julia es kommt auf den kontext einer
wenn sie sagen die einen die piloten
weil sagen wir mal die berliner gucken
gerade mit live dabei ist jedes kind was
damit gemeint ist und zwar nicht nur
männer dass man jetzt anfängt und sagte
damit sind nur männer gemeint und ich
fühle mich davon ausgeschlossen da
stellen sich wirklich feministinnen blöd
und stellen sich gegen einiges artikel
schon vierjähriges kind vor nicht klar
[Musik]